when I am in a room and I fart I'm being
me I'm giving you all of me I'm not
holding back no one is allowed to fart
around me
I'm Matt and Chris hi my question is do
you have people in your life who are
allowed to fart and people who aren't
what a great question uh my buddies were
over the other day and one of them
farted and I was appalled and disgusted
and said no don't do that wow and he was
rightfully offended because apparently a
few minutes earlier our other buddy
farted and I giggled
I had to dig deep inside myself and
question why can't you and why can he
and why
um
and I can't find any explanation other
than you're just not that guy like you
just can't
and I proceeded to make a list of people
in my life who can and the list people
yeah I can't find any similarities she's
funny
um what's that about am I just being a
fart gatekeeper does it make sense
think about the people in your lives who
can and can't have fart rooms here's
what I think
no one can fart around me yeah don't not
no and I can also fart around everyone
that's how everyone feels but it's like
it's like you're on spit like you can
look at your own spit when someone else
spits it's like you [ __ ] pig people
farting it is because it leaves a
[ __ ] Trace but it's like you know
somebody farts and it's like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] Pig like David
Sullivan farts so much you know I was
just with him yeah of course he did
because he's got that big [ __ ] head I
don't like that and he's [ __ ] gross
and he [ __ ] wears shorts and he farts
and [ __ ] can't smell it
so I can't eat cheese man and then he
does anyway where's Savannah yeah you
paid the price we were in Savannah we
were in Savannah and he was he was there
in Savannah and did his Film Festival
his film festival coincided with Mike oh
cool and he was there and he was like
yeah I'll get this without cheese though
oh wow and then the guy left and I was
like man you [ __ ] Gotta Eat Cheese
like nah it makes me fart man if I eat
that special around people I'll start
farting immediately man why does he act
like he cares he doesn't care that guy's
a [ __ ] disgusting fart machine so
dick he doesn't my point is dick he
doesn't eat cheese a lot when I'm around
me but I make him do it and then I tell
him not to fart because I want him
that's torturous but okay so here's
where you saw a movie
you've been bypassing eating cheese so
much and not farting but now you're
subjecting people around you to the
stench of your insides here's some
Parmesan eat it and fart your way out oh
I want to play a game
hahaha
[Music]
took so long to get to the joke you know
oh walks around if you're like oh okay
so the detectives later
I think I know what happens yeah it's
Chris Rock for some reason
I don't know what happened Chris Rock
Okay so
I smell farts so Sam Jackson background
God damn farts no one
is allowed to fart around me I just
watched spiral okay
no one is allowed to fart around me no
one is allowed to burp her on me no one
is allowed to be [ __ ] disgusting
around me without my Express
permission Moses [ __ ] signed
contract saying it's okay I mean sign
your permissions you know you need
signed permission I'm talking about my
farts so far a [ __ ] just keep it walk
out of the [ __ ] room
walk out of the [ __ ] room you're
gonna fart I won't you won't but that's
great you don't it's gross your farts
smell like [ __ ] death that's not true
your farts smell like decomposed corpses
after 30 seconds I put Altoids up my
butt okay well they [ __ ] don't work
okay
but none of this is true guys I do know
what she means though about how some
people are less gross when they fart and
some people are more even if they're the
same fart but for me it's a no fart rule
just don't do it your house is in no
fart Zone unless it's you and I'm alone
yeah right right are you dude if I'm in
a room with somebody I don't [ __ ]
fart
no the other way around you no because
you've got to be honest when I am in a
room and I fart I'm being me I'm giving
you all of me I'm not holding back no
one wants respectful that's not
respectful no one wants all of you they
go I go you're welcome that's yeah come
on you want me to not be me you're a
psychopath
you're straight up psychopath who was
the person that called in we're just
kind of started to talk about oh yeah I
think that there's a no farts on it
that's really I really like that you
have a list of people who can and can't
fart yeah and I think that you should
brief people on who can and can't yeah
yeah totally but like and then when they
say why not me you say honestly because
I think you're more disgusting than the
other guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're the kind of guy I don't want
to smell their insides yeah you're gross
you gross me out already yeah and then
when you fart it puts you over the
[ __ ] Edge because you're disgusting
you [ __ ] pig so dick so I think but
also some parts sound wet some people do
well come on I don't do I want my shit's
dry but I don't do wet ones but
sometimes you hear like their cheeks
you know and it's disgusting as [ __ ]
yeah it's so gross and then dude have
you ever farted but and then [ __ ] by
mistake not me I never honestly I
actually never have done that I've heard
people talk about me too Eric Griffin
talked about it last night oh well then
now that is gross yep he farted dude and
he didn't know any any [ __ ] when he took
a Steppy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then like get up and be like oh I
bet when he tells the story he describes
the farts 100 yeah yeah yeah because
that's his signature move all right
first time I met him I was astonished at
how many times he did this I know yeah I
know it's disgusting one-on-one yeah I
was farting [ __ ] coming everything
was that dude with privates everything
everything is squirting okay cool
hello hello
[Music]